it would help a lot if Alexa remembered
me what I said previously right is it is
it trying to use some memories for the
customer it is using a lot of memory
within that so right now not so much in
terms of okay which restaurant do you
prefer right that is a more long-term
memory but within the short-term memory
within the session it is remembering how
many people did you so if you said buy
four tickets not has made an implicit
assumption that you were gonna have you
need for at least four seats at a
restaurant right so these are the kind
of context it's preserving between these
skills but within that session what are
you asking the right question in terms
of for it to be more and more useful it
has to have more long-term memory and
that's also an open question and again
this was still early days so for me I
mean every is different but yeah I'm
definitely not representative of the
general population the sense that I do
the same thing every day like I eat the
same that I do everything the same and
the same thing we're the same thing
clearly this or the black shirt so it's
frustrating when it elects it doesn't
get what I'm saying because I had to
correct her every time the exact same
way this has to do with certain songs
like she doesn't know certain weird
songs only and doesn't know I've
complained to Spotify about this talk to
the Rd head of our idea Spotify stairway
to heaven I have to correct it every
time it really doesn't play Led Zeppelin
correctly so I should figure you should
send me or next time it fails the scene
for you to send it to me you will take
care of it okay well let's upload is one
of my favorite it works for me so I'm
like shocked it doesn't work for you
this is an official bug report I'll put
it I'll make it public every tweet it
we're gonna fix this there would have
been pay anyway but the point is you
know I'm pretty boring and do the same
thing but I'm sure most people do the
same set of things do you see Alexa sort
of utilizing that in the future for
improving the experience yes and not
only utilizing it's already doing some
of it we call it more aware Alexa is
becoming more self learning so
Alexa is now Auto correcting millions
and millions of utterances in us without
any human supervision involved the way
desert is let's take an example of a
particular song didn't work for you what
do you do next
you either it played the wrong song and
you said Alexa no that's not the song I
want or you say likes a play that you
try it again and that is a signal to
Alexa that she may have done something
wrong and from that perspective we can
learn if there's that failure pattern or
that action of song a was played when
song B was requested yes
it's very common with station names
because play NPR you can have n be
confused as an M and then you for a
certain accent like mine
people confuse my N and M all the time
and because I have a Indian accent there
confusable to humans it is for Alexa too
and in that part but it starts Auto
correcting and we collect we correct lot
of these automatically without a human
looking at the failures so the one of
the things that's for me missing in
Alessa I don't know from a
representative customer but every time I
correct it it would be nice to know that
that made a difference yes you know I
mean like that yeah sort of like I I
heard you like some acknowledgement of
that we worked a lot with with Tesla
study the autopilot and so on and a
large amount of the customers they use
Tesla autopilot they feel like they're
always teaching the system uh-huh
they're almost excited by the
possibility teaching I don't know if
Alexa customers generally think of it as
they're teaching to improve the system I
think and that's a really powerful thing
against yeah I would say it's a spectrum
some customers do think that way and
some would be annoyed by Alexa
acknowledging that or so there's a again
no one you know while there are certain
patterns not everyone is the same in
this way but we believe that again
customers helping Alexa is a tenet for
in terms of improving it dancing more
self learning is by again this is like
fully unsupervised right there is no
human in the loop and no labeling
happening and based on your actions as a
customer
Alexa becomes smarter again it's early
days but I think this whole area of
teachable AI is gonna get bigger and
bigger in the whole space especially in
the AI assistance space
you